Film Courage: You talked about being in television
and with some of the jobs [you held] the hours
were so long that you really didn’t have
much of a creative life?
So can you talk about leaving that world and
going to do your own thing with the writing,
your schedule, etc.?
Andrew Horng: Yeah, it was from one extreme
to the other.
In one situation I’m coming home late at
night tired and trying to write, falling asleep
after like three sentences.
And then all of the sudden, I have all these
hours, I’m writing, trying to work on my
process, trying to figure out exactly what
I need to do as a writer to get the best product
out there.
So I left the TV industry and I really wasn’t
sure what type of a writer I was.
I thought I was a writer who needed to focus
on creating those rich characters and developing
that and trying to explore.
But I started to realize that I was a writer
that needed more organization or structure
and I started to learn more about the structure
of screenplays, scenes and everything like
that.
Film Courage: How was that having, so much
free time?
Because sometimes having too much free time
is a curse because you don’t structure it
and just think “Oh, I can just do that tomorrow.”
And then it’s a week later.
Andrew Horng: Right.
You kind of expand your days and the days
kind of seem like one.
What I would do is I’d go to place to write.
I still do this, I’d go to the library.
That’s still probably my favorite place
to write.
There are some other places to go, too.
I heard the writer of THE STING actually wrote
his screenplay in an airport.
He had the busy people shuffling back and
forth and he was able to do it.
I’ve also heard of other writers (it’s
kind of a little bit extreme) but that actually
checks into a hotel, removes all of his clothes
and gives them to a friend and says “I’ve
got to finish this screenplay or else I’m
going to be losing money and I’m totally
by myself without anything.”
At some point the maid is going to come in.
That’s a little bit more extreme.
Film Courage: Don’t try that at the library
by the way.
Andrew Horng: Yeah, I’m probably not going
to try that at the library but…who knows?
Maybe?
I’ve heard of one writer who actually wrote
on a boat from the US to Asia (some sort of
boat) and he didn’t have any distractions
with cell phones or anything like that.
He just needed some time and there was a deadline,
too.
I’d say any type of deadline (at least for
me) really does help.
But it’s got to be the right deadline.
It can’t be any arbitrary deadline.
You can’t just say ‘by tomorrow I’m
going to be done.’
Film Courage: Yeah and writing at the library
is great because you can’t always get Wi-Fi
unless you log into their system and agree
to their terms.
So sometimes it’s nice to just say “You
know what?
I’m not going to have Wi-Fi in here.”
And you get stuff done.
Andrew Horng: Sometimes Wi-Fi is your biggest
enemy.
I mean sometimes you can use it to research,
but sometimes you want to shy away from it.
I actually got rid of my Internet so I have
to go to the gym in my complex to use the
Internet and it keeps me a little bit more
focused.
Film Courage: Interesting.
And that was a conscious decision because
you knew it distracted you?
Andrew Horng: I didn’t want to be researching
all the time.
Yeah it really puts me in the zone and I don’t
also only write at my place, I go out.
I do a lot of writing outside.
Film Courage: Do people ever stop you and
ask what you’re doing?
Andrew Horng: Yeah…people are curious and
I give them a little pitch.
Film Courage: What’s your pitch?
Andrew Horng: Right now I am working on an
ensemble film.
It’s a high school drama about bullying
and abuse and there are lots of different
characters and lots of storylines that intersect
and it’s kind of like the TRAFFIC of bullying
or CRASH of bullying (that issue).
And it’s all set in one location (it’s
a school) and that’s what I’m working
on for now.